dee
[音楽]
皆さんに一つ
考えてほしいことがあります
あなたにしか出来ないことで何ですか
そうあなたにしかできないこと
いやいやそんな私にしかできないこと
なんてないよう私特別な人じゃないし言っ
て
思うかもしれません
でも
あなたにしかできないこと
誰にだって自分にしかできない何かがある
と
私はそう思っています
今日は私の人生のストーリーをみなさんに
ご紹介してそこから見つけた
自分にしかできないことをお話ししたいと
思います
私は今なら県の高校で英語の先生をして
いるのですが
学生時代はここ
奈良教育大学で学んでいました
実はこの奈良教育大学に今の自分に
つながる世界への扉があったんです
それでは私の生い立ちからご紹介したいと
思います
いつから学校の先生を目指すようになった
の
よく聞かれる質問の一つです
掃除機なところ明確な答えは見つからない
のですが
思い返せばそう学校の頃までさかのぼり
ます
小学生の時
控えめでおとなしくであまり活発なタイプ
ではなかったのですが学校に行くのが
とっても好きでした
先生も大好きでした
小学校1年生の時
小学校1年生の最後の日に担任の先生とお
別れするのが寂しくて泣いたのを覚えてい
ます
今から20年も前の話ですが今でもよく
覚えています
中学生で一つ
大きなチャレンジをします
生徒会長選挙に立候補します
生徒会長にはなれなかったものの生徒会
役員の一人として
いろいろな経験をさせていただきました
学校全体をまとめて行事を作り上げること
の他のしたやりがいをとても感じていまし
た
第一志望だった高校に進学して
ここでも生徒会活動に熱中します
体育祭や球技大会の企画代表を務めて
思い返せば自分の青春時代ってまさにあの
瞬間だったなーって思います
生徒主体を大切にしている学校でいろんな
学校行事を生徒が中心になって造り上げて
いました
学校をまとめたり行事を企画したり
自分たちが学校回しているんだってそんな
実感がありました
でもそれと同時に生徒主体の裏には
たくさんの先生方の計り知れない大きな
サポートがあったことも子供ながらに感じ
ていました
一生懸命頑張っている生徒たちが活動し
やすい環境をつくってくれて支えてくれて
守ってくれて
そんな生成方の姿を見ながら
先生て素敵な仕事だな
自分も学校の先生になってそうやって生徒
たちと関わっていきたいな
そう思って教育学部を目指します
そしてここ
奈良教育大学に入学します
この選択が今の自分につながる大事な分岐
点でした
ここからたくさんの選択や小川の物語が
始まります
まず最初の出会いは
esd ユネスコクラブでした
奈良教育大学は日本で最初にユネスコ
スクールに加盟した大学として
esd 持続可能な開発のための教育と
いうものに大学全体で取り組んでいます
私たち一人ひとりが
sdg ずを達成するより良い世界を作る
一因になる
そのための教育といったところです
この esd に取り組んでいるユネスコ
クラブという学生団体があります
自分の学科の先輩に誘われてユネスコ
クラブに入ります
これがすべての始まりでした
大学2年生
あることに気がつきました
大学に入学してから自分から
何もチャレンジできてないなーって
自分は英語の学科に所属していましたが
海外に行ったことはありませんでした
自分の英語って本当に世界で通用するのか
な
そんな疑問がわいてきて
とにかく海外に行ってみよう
でもせっかくだったらただ旅行とかじゃ
なくて何か自分のためにも誰かのためにも
なる
そんなことがしたいな
と思って見つけたのが
カンボジアでの2週間の教育ボランティア
でした
一人で申し込みました
初めての海外で陥没や
2週間
しかも一人で
なかなか大きなチャレンジですよね
自分も申し込んだ後に気がつきました
そこでいろんな事を感じました
なんせ初めての海外です
英語は今まで日本で聞いていたものとは
全く違う
アクセントの英語
空港からホテルまで送迎してくれた
タクシーの運転手さんの英語が全く
聞き取れなくて
この先2週間大丈夫かなぁってとても不安
になりました
今からもう6年も前のカンボジアです
まだまだ発展途上でした
ためてある冷たい水を桶ですくって浴びる
お風呂
流れないトイレ
壁や窓で仕切られていない学校の教室
乗り物も食べ物も全てが自分にとっては
新鮮でした
有名な世界遺産アンコールワットに行った
時には出口のところで裸足の
小さな子供が待っていて
wander wander
と
手を差し伸べて寄ってきました
20年間日本でしか生活したことがなかっ
た自分
初めて見た外国の姿
貧しい生活の現場に驚きました
でも
とても印象的だったのはカンボジアの子供
たちの
笑顔です
肩から下げている鞄の中にはノート1冊
ぺ日本教科書は思っていませんでした
ている服も汚れていたり穴が開いていたり
でもとっても楽しそうに一生懸命勉強して
いました
みんなそれぞれいろんな夢を持っていて
あのまっすぐでキラキラした目
今でもとても心に残っています
彼らにとっての幸せって何なんだろう
あの時とても考えました
自分がいろんな世界の課題に感心を持って
考え始めるきっかけになったのがこの
カンボジアでの経験でした
そして国家ここからいろんな挑戦をして
いきます
esd やユネスコの活動で日本中
いろんなところに行ったり色んな国にも
行きました
ありがたいことにたくさんの人との出会い
に恵まれました
一つチャレンジするとまたその次の機会に
つながる
自分の人生を豊かにしてくれました
奈良教育大学に入学してユネスコクラブに
入って esd を学ぶ
というこの選択がその先たくさんの出会い
や世界への扉につながっていたんです
ここまでのお話を聞いていただいて
なんとなくこの人をいろんなことをしてき
たんだなぁとか成功者なんだなって
思っていただけるかもしれません
でも実はそんなことないんです
いろんな失敗や経験も
失敗や挫折も経験してきました次はそんな
挫折のお話です
ユネスコの活動をしていて英語もまぁ
そこそこ話せる
そんなこんなでチャンスをいただいて
ユースユネスコ climate
action network という
気候変動に関わるニュースの世界規模の
ネットワークの立ち上げにかかわることに
なりました
世界中から
ユネスコ活動に関わっている15人の
ユースが集まってオンラインで活動してい
ます
こんな簿中があるよと聞くとなんでも
とりあえずやってみようって思ってしまう
自分なのでエントリーしたのですがこれが
まあ大変なことになりました
奈良教育大学のような
ユネスコスクールと言われる学校は世界中
に1万校以上あるのですが今回私はこの
ネットワークの代表として関わっています
1万校の代表なんて想像はるかに超える
責任の重さですし
集まった15人のメンバーがまーすすごい
他のメンバーとの差を感じます
責任の重さに逃げたくなりました
この中での活動のため会議はオンラインで
そして時差の関係で日本では真夜中に行わ
れていました
毎日のように英語でたくさんのメールが
届きます
他のメンバーのすごさや役割の大変さから
自分の存在意義を感じ取ることができなく
て
やっぱり自分には無理だったなあと逃げて
しまっていました
そうして悩んでいた時ふと自分の中に降り
てきた問いがあります
それが
自分にしかできないことは
です
今日最初に皆さんにお聞きしましたね
自分にしかできないことは
このすごい15人の中で自分にしかでき
ないことって何だろうって考えてみました
なんせすごい人たちなので気候変動や生物
多様性といった分野にはとっても詳しくて
そういう専門分野ではか内容がありません
し専門的な議論にもついていくことができ
ません
でも自分にはこのユネスコスクールという
学校のつながりがあるし esd などの
教育の分野でこれまで積み重ねてきた経験
や強み思いがある
これなら負けないなっ
この強みを生かして頑張ろう
そう思って立ち上がりました
そしてつい先月の話なんですが
ユネスコスクールのグローバル
スチューデントフォーラムという
3日間のオンラインの国際会議がありまし
て
このネットワークの代表としてフォーラム
の司会やスピーカーを務めました
きっと数年前の自分だったらこんなこと
できなかったと思います
ここでやっと自分の存在意義を感じ取る
ことができました
自分にしかできないこと
私を立ち直らせてくれたキーワードです
次は英語の先生としての今の自分に
つながるまでのお話をします
大学院生の時世界青年の船という内閣府が
主催している青年国際交流事業に参加し
ました
世界11か国
240人のユースとともに40日間の船の
旅をしました
どこまでも続く太平洋の上
一つの船の中で共同生活をするんです
世界中から集まっているので本当に
いろんな価値観や文化を持った仲間が
集まっています
40日間もある旅なのでいろんな
プログラムがあるんですがその中でも
大きなものとして七つのテーマに分かれて
ディスカッションをするという機会があり
ました
私は教育に関するグループに入って世界中
の仲間と教育の問題について語り合いまし
た
みんなそれぞれ
教育に関する異なるバックグラウンドを
持っていていろんな
教育のあり方を感じました
education is the key
to change the world
ディスカッションの中で私たちが何度も口
にした言葉です
教育は世界を変えるカギだ
興味深いことに
他のテーマでディスカッションをしていた
グループもやっぱり最後は教育の問題に
行き着いたそうです
教育って大事だっやっぱり自分も
人生を通して教育に関わりたい
そう思った瞬間でした
それと同時に
教員になる前にもっといろんな世界の教育
を見てみたい
日本で生まれて日本でしか教育を受けた
ことがない自分
もっといろんな教育のあり方を見てから
教員になるという夢を叶えたい
そう思いました
そこで選択したチャレンジが
オーストラリアでの
日本語教師アシスタントです
世界青年の船で出会った仲間に紹介して
もらって参加するチャンスを得ました
日本では外国語として皆さん英語を学んで
おられると思いますが
オーストラリアでも多くの子供たちが外国
語として日本語を学んでいます
オーストラリアの学校で実際に働いてみて
日本の教育との違いをたくさん見つけまし
た
授業のスタイルオンラインの活用
先生の働き方
言語学習の方法
学校行事など
すべてが新しい
発見の連続でした
しカス
ここで悲劇が起こります
オーストラリアでも日本と同じように
コロナの波がやってきました
完全なロックダウンが始まって日本への
帰国指示が出て
急遽ギリギリのフライトチケットを手に
入れて日本に帰ってきました
志半ばで帰ってくることになったので
とてもショックは大きかったのですが
くよくよしかしていても仕方がありません
環境のせいにするんじゃなくて自分で何か
アクションを起こさないと
あの時自分を救ってくれたとい
自分にしかできないことは
という問いを自問自答して
そして今度はそれに加えて
今しかできないことはあっ
この2つを自問自答しながらいろんな
アクションを起こしていきました
ここまで自分が経験してきたことを色々お
話しさせていただきました
カンボジアでの教育ボランティアデー
貧困の現状や夢を持って一生懸命学ぶ
子どもの姿を見たこと
世界青年の船に参加して海外の青年と教育
について語り合ったこと
オーストラリアで日本語教師として働いた
こと
ユネスコのネットワークの運営に関わって
挫折から何とか立ち上がったこと
いろんな経験をしてきました
こんな私なのでよく言われることがあり
ます
本当に先生になりたいの
こんなにいろんな経験をしたんだったら
もっと他に出来ることがあるんじゃない
もったいないよっ
そう言われて
自分でも悩みました
先生になりたくて
この大学に来たけど
本当にそれが自分のしたいことなのかなっ
ていう
でもここであのとい
自分にしかできないことは
に戻ります
日本中世界中いろんなところに行って
いろんな人に出会っていろんなものを見て
感じて考えて
そんな自分だからこそできる
いやそんな自分にしかできない
先生としての関わりがある自分にしか語れ
ないことがある
そう思いました
education 1先
to change the ball で
だからこそ自分が教員としてやりたいこと
がある
成功体験ばっかりじゃなくて初めての海外
で英語でうまくコミュニケーションがとれ
なかったこと
世界のすごい人たちと自分を比べて挫折し
たこと
いろんな世界の課題について考えてより
良い世界を作りたいって
行動してきたこと
そんな自分だからこそできることがある
そう思いました
だから僕は先生になりたいやっぱり自分が
したいことってこれだったんだ
そう思っていま
先生という仕事をしています
学校では
英語を教えている
というよりは英語を使って子どもたちと
一緒に学んでいるというのが自分には
しっくりきます
自分にしかできないことを大切にして海外
の学校とオンライン交流を企画したり自分
自身が学生時代にずっと学んできた sdg
ずを扱って世界の課題を一緒に考えたりも
しています
自分が子供のころ学校が大好きで先生が
大好きでこれまでお世話になった先生
一人ひとりのことを今でも深く覚えている
ように
目の前の生徒たちにとって先生との出会い
は
人生の大きな財産になると思っています
だからこそ
政党にとって自分との出会いが
その後の人生にとってどんな小さなもので
もいい
何かその先を照らすきっかけになって
ほしい
道をひらく
た音になってほしい
そう思っています
まだまだ先生の卵の殻を破って歩き出した
小さなひろこですがこの志だけは立派に
持って毎日を過ごしています
自分にしかできないことは
これまでの選択と挑戦を支えてきてくれた
といいです
これまでしてきた経験
出会いそのすべてがつながって今の自分が
ある
やっと自分が本当にしたいことが見つかっ
たと思っています
大学そして大学院と7年半の学生生活を
過ごしました
かなり遠回りをしたかもしれませんがこれ
でよかったんだと思っています
あなたにしかできないことは
何ですか
何も立派な答えを考える必要はありません
自分も
本当に好きな事自分が心の底からワクワク
することって何ですか
ここにおられる皆さんの多くは中高生だと
思います
学生のみなさんはまだそれが手にそれが
見つかっていないという人も心配する必要
はありません
自分も遠回りをしてやっと見つけました
そのために
いろんな世界に飛び出してみましょう
いろんな人に出会ってみましょう
いろんなチョイスをしてみましょう
踏み出したその一歩が次のチョイスに
つながって
その先にきっと
自分にしか出来ないことが見つかります
ありがとうございました
[拍手]